[Música]
bom dia a todos é eu eu tenho uma
história relativamente comum
eu sou uma pessoa sou casado mulher
maravilhosa tem um filho incrível é ter
um trabalho como professor tem uma casa
e um carro paga o imposto fica nervoso
quando vou dar palestras do ted x esse
tipo de coisa que acontece com todo
mundo mas eu tem um motivo para o ataque
é eu acho que eu conseguir meio por
acaso
consegui na minha vida pessoal e na
minha vida profissional é fazer uma
coisa incrível conseguir manter vivas
aquelas paixões que me encantaram quando
tinha 11 anos de idade
aos 11 anos de idade morava em niterói
uma família de classe média mais
amorosos irmão irmã de 11 anos na escola
que estudava fui convidado para fazer
parte do grupo escoteiro da escola é e
aí a minha vida mudou radicalmente a
minha vida passou a ser povoada por
jogos amizades aventuras incríveis
isso foi uma revolução para mim
incorporei isso na minha vida de tal
maneira que me detive do movimento
escoteiro durante muitos anos fui chefe
escoteiro antes de virar professor eu
acho até que em determinado professor
foi um pouco em função disso a e na
minha prática profissional eu sempre
acaba incorporando valores do movimento
escoteiro aprender fazendo
trabalhar em equipe buscar lúdico buscar
o contato com a natureza
isso sempre me inspirou como professor e
até hoje eu busco nas minhas aulas
trazer esse tipo de coisa mas
principalmente fora de aula num projecto
que eu faço no colégio de aplicação da
ufrj chamado núcleo de atividades em
física na esse projeto ele congrega já o
longo dos últimos 20 anos 21 anos o
fundo nasce em 1997 e esse projeto já
congregou
aproximadamente 300 jovens que são
trazidos para o projeto a cada ano cerca
de 20 a 25 foi um grupo de 25 pessoas
com os quais a gente trabalha atividades
buscando por um lado envolver as pessoas
com ciência física com as formas um
senso de uma forma geral e fazê-los
perceber que eles podem construir o
próprio conhecimento e podem a partir
desse conhecimento agir sobre o mundo de
acordo com as escolhas que eles podem
fazer
em segundo lugar que conhecimento
aventura e serviços não precisam estar
separados podem andar juntos e é muito
divertido que lhe são devidos e
finalmente construir um ambiente em que
as pessoas possam fomentar amizades
amizade que perpassem gerações que criar
uma verdadeira comunidade de pessoas
envolvidas com isso essa falta da festa
de 20 anos no fim do ano passado
os jovens mais jovens que ainda estão no
grupo estão prestando enem agora os mais
velhos levam os filhos para a festa
é muito comum que é deter anos como a
gente chama ele não apareça nas
atividades querendo ajudar querendo
participar se tornou marca do nam
esse é o convite que ele recebe para
entrar no mar é mais ou menos isso é o
que passa pela cabeça de vocês deve
passar pela cabeça dele
a primeira coisa que eles fazem depois
de decodificar isso aí na reunião para a
qual estão sendo convidados e nessa
reunião alguns veteranos vão lá na
primeira reunião do ano
eles fazem uma semana eles são
desafiados para os jogos na filosofia
são jogos entre os veteranos e um novo
grupo de calouros em que eles vão se
encontram num no parque e fazem os
detrans propõe na verdade várias
atividades
é desafiador jogos simples frisby habib
passar por debaixo da perna revezamento
de pegar a bola na farinha o que seja
ele quem inventou isso
o importante é que todos os jogos são
absolutamente discaradamente trapaceados
para que os veteranos ganhe sempre
mesmo assim houve um ano em que os
calores vencer
fica tudo bem porque no final os
veteranos explicam que era tudo uma
brincadeira e convidam os novatos para
um piquenique de confraternização e aí
já ficam todos amigos
além dessas a partir dessas nesse
momento inicial ao longo das reuniões
semanais né
a gente faz várias atividades algumas
delas é tem um aspecto de serviço
os monitores do naf desenvolve
atividades em laboratório com alunos das
séries inferiores
então eles precisam aprender melhor
aquilo que eles vão ensinar e fazer
orientar os grupos mais novos
outra coisa que a gente faz que é um
serviço pra escola é hospedar a noite de
observação da escola de observação do
céu ter dom
então nós convidamos astrônomos para dar
palestras divulgamos o evento na escola
trazemos telescópios colocamos os alunos
na quadra de noite e observamos o céu a
lua júpiter o que seja mas o charme
mesmo do de participar do nafta é poder
participar das aventuras científicas
a primeira aventura científica vão ser
propostas abertas que vão envolver
alguns testes de medição e essa edição
vai ter que acontecer numa aventura ao
ar livre
a primeira proposta é discutir que
temperatura marca o termômetro
quando a água está fervendo essa
aparentemente simples pergunta leva a
milhares de elaborações teóricas e
experimentais e faz vários experimentos
sobre as grandezas podem afetar isso
e finalmente alguém traz a questão de
ser a que a pressão atmosférica afeta a
temperatura de ebulição da água
vamos vamos testar isso como alguém
eventualmente chega à conclusão de que a
gente pode subir uma montanha bem alta e
ferver água em cima e ver o que acontece
isso evolui para uma grande aventura que
é subir o pico da tijuca a mais de mil
metros de altitude aqui no floresta da
tijuca no rio de janeiro
e nós traçamos um mapa de onde nós vamos
fazer em cada ponto da trilha medições a
diferentes altitudes e se aprende a se
orientar e vamos coletando os dados eles
são eles chegando já no pico da tijuca
é em que cada equipe são divididos em
quatro equipes cada equipe tem o seu
termômetro gente ferve a água e todo
mundo junto de cada equipe coleta os
seus dados esses dados depois são
tratados e viram uma discussão teórica
conceitual bem legal
a segunda aventura científica ainda um
pouco mais elaborada que se na primeira
eles tiveram que lidar com fazer uma
medição e entender como funciona um
instrumento de medida na segunda
aventura científica
agora eles precisam eles mesmos
construíram um instrumento de medida e
se a primeira aventura científica foi
pra cima
a segunda aventura científica é para
baixo
eles são desafiados a construir
profundímetro aparelhos que podem dizer
um mergulhador aqui profundidade ele se
encontra dentro da já que o grupo em
arraial do cabo onde a gente trabalha
junto com operadoras de mergulho e eles
constroem alguns profundímetro eu trouxe
aqui alguns modelos
esse é um deles há na verdade uma
maneira fechada num canto que está
vedado em que ele entra na água
emborcado assim e aprisionando uma certa
quantidade de araque à medida que você
afunda a pressão da água momento essa
água cumpriu aqui
quanto maior a pressão mais ela
cumprindo tal forma que a altura da
coluna de ar aqui dentro de alguma
maneira que eles podem prever
matematicamente profundidade ele está
ele só precisa saber como fazer essas
marquinhos aqui seja como calibrar o
profundímetro um outro modelo aqui veio
de um design diferente porque eles
perceberam que quando tudo está aberto
assim embaixo pode entrar bolhas aqui da
própria respiração mergulhadores com
isso aqui evitava que isso acontecesse
finalmente é interessante como o
conceito teórico da coisa leva é nesse
caso os alunos a se relacionar em dois
campos teórico diferentes do curso de
física dele para chegar na equação que
vai dizer para eles onde as marquinhas
têm que ser feitas
chamada a equação da sabrina ele precisa
juntar
além disso devem que é da estática com a
lei de bolinha do estudo dos gases
quando estão livros de física diferente
isso ficou tão impactante para sabrina
que foi o menino terceiro grupo do nef
que quando perguntado uma vez sobre como
foi o processo de fazer profundímetro
ela disse cara foi incrível a gente
pegou uma equação
ela tinha muita dificuldade em física e
matemática para ela que não foi assim um
momento de epifania que tem uma equação
de um livro uma equação do outro livro e
aí pa
a gente fez uma equação nossa equação
nossa que nunca na história da
humanidade tinha sido escrito
eu imagino que ela achava que ia ganhar
o prêmio nobel não fez não aconteceu mas
ela é uma excelente antropólogos hoje em
dia além de além de fazer a
possibilidade do profundímetro é a gente
orienta uma atividade que acontece em
paralelo que é uma actividade de
observação do costão da fauna do costão
marinha de arraial do cabo com o apoio
dos professores monitores biologia dos
alunos a nota 1 com que suas observações
sobre riqueza diversidade da fauna
marinha e registram isso em cadernos que
eles mesmos construíram e que são
passados a cada ano para a nova geração
do nam que quando vai fazer essa
atividade pode se basear nos registros
feitos pelos nosos veteranos
obviamente a gente também aproveita para
brincar um pouco jogam ignorei faz um
monte de atividades é fora do barco
a gente aproveita para visitar vários
centros de de pesquisa do centro
brasileiro de pesquisas físicas na urca
com o grupo conheceu os laboratórios de
pesquisa e no final do ano a gente faz
uma atividade é de uma jornada de
integração com outro núcleo de física
que existe no cefet de nova iguaçu
a professora marta máximo em que os
alunos trocam fazem palestras uns para
os outros e cada um conta o que fez ao
longo do ano para os colegas do outro
grupo
a última atividade do ano é um
acampamento na sede guapimirim do parque
nacional da serra dos órgãos onde vão na
filósofos de todas as gerações é uma
grande festa de congraçamento de
encerramento do ano a gente repassa tudo
que a gente fez ao longo do ano
além dessas coisas que acontecem todo
ano
de vez em quando a gente faz as
atividades mais malucas de quatro em
quatro anos mais ou menos a gente faz a
mega aventura científica que é um
desafio realmente pesado a gente convida
os participantes a fazerem um
acampamento selvagem de cinco a sete
dias de duração em que eles têm que
vencer vários desafios práticos tem que
construir os seus próprios abrigos sejam
conseguindo fazer isso no final do
primeiro dia eles vão dormir ao relento
ou provavelmente na chuva que chove o
tempo todo lá eles precisam fazer os
seus próprios banheiros e precisão
cozinhar sua própria comida enfim eles
precisam se virar
além disso pra se não fosse um desafio
suficientemente pesada agente introduz
toda uma mística próprio envolve os
jogos normalmente está associada a algum
cataclisma terrível vai acontecer sob a
terra vamos ser abduzido por alienígenas
uma coisa do gênero ea única chance de
salvação do planeta é eles conseguirem
vencer esse desafio que se coloca na
forma de um jogo tudo sempre obviamente
terminando muito bem as pessoas salva o
mundo e no final a gente termina com uma
grande fogueira eo congraçamento muito
grande com músicas esquetes teatrais
muita brincadeira é não ter colocado
essa falta sou eu de bigode realmente
mas essa é uma longa tradição na fila
toda mega oficialato nas pessoas estão
organizando o jogo tem que ir de bigode
mesmo as meninas elas botam bigodes em
falsas e pelo menos o primeiro de seis
anos atrás a gente fez uma atividade
única na frente mas giga
a ge ganharam uma atividade de 15 dias
de duração que começava no rio de
janeiro e arraial do cabo de arraial do
cabo subia para casimiro de abreu aldeia
velha e terminava iluminar mais de 140
quilômetros em que eles tinham que usar
canoas barco à vela mergulhar andar de
bicicleta 13 fazer uma balsa para
atravessar outra parte caminhar escalar
e vencer vários desafios que eram
colocados para eles que eles tinham
combinar as habilidades que eles
desenvolveram nos dois anos anteriores
até conseguir vencer o desafio final
é no final a gente tinha uma noite de
encerramento em que novamente o desafio
era vencido e salvamos o mundo em 107 e
a agente matriz amiga nossa era
professor de teatro na escola mariano
consumir que interpretava a dama do lago
que fazem o encerramento neste
encerramento
a gente montou o próximo à fogueira na
beira do rio dois espelhos formando um
ângulo de 90 graus e cada pessoa chamada
individualmente pra ela restasse algo
sobre a essência das pessoas sobre a
nossa relação com o nosso passado nosso
futuro foi absolutamente emocionante
obviamente terminou e choradeira o meu
meu ponto aqui é o seguinte é uma vez
perguntaram por um universitário
participou com gente do nef que era isso
na época ele estava participando ele
disse olha abre aspas
roberto pensa lá o que ele gosta de
fazer e aí ele dá um jeito de votar
física ali no meio para justificar
fazendo com os alunos e é isso mesmo
não tenho dúvidas que esse mesmo meu
ponto aqui é o seguinte a gente passa a
faculdade de licenciatura todo houve um
dos professores que a você tem que
pensar no interesse dos alunos tem que
planejar suas atividades pedagógicas a
partir do que os alunos querem aquilo
que motiva eles meu ponto é que beleza
isso é verdade mas a gente tem que
pensar também eu acho que é isso que vai
mudar a educação
naquilo que motiva a gente como um
professor
aquilo que motiva aquilo que interessa
gente o que eu quero fazer com que os
alunos
é nesse momento em que a gente faz
transforma nossa prática pedagógica e
educação não uma coisa uniformizante
exigente e cheio de caixinhas para uma
coisa que é uma coisa livre e criativa e
parte da nossa própria auto expressão
daquilo que a gente é para isso que eu
queria falar pra vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]